now the the the other piece of business
I wanted to get to and I wanted to I
told Kalyn last night when I saw him
creeping around the [ __ ] Laugh
Factory 11 o'clock get up Bobby get him
a goose you're on set doing a show like
when I'm going set out the next day I'm
I'm sleeping or I'm at home learning my
lines well that's why you're like a rep
for doing my that's why that's why I
enjoy on Netflix third season and that's
why I ain't never been cut out of no
movie I ain't never been cut out of no
movie cuz they're like it's too good
even if it's even if it's it's just too
good but I wanted to bring this up with
you because I was gonna post yo coming
on the fighter and the kid today yes
okay and like I said I do consider you a
friend
I consider Cal and a friend we've always
been mutually supportive though and you
threatened me Earl you said you'd [ __ ]
me up and all that stuff I'm ready to
put this down like this because when I
was on my way over and I was like I was
gonna go yo on my way to fighting
hurricane and and I took a picture I did
a little one of my classic videos my
videos are kind of iconic now are they
come on I I mean when I put that camera
up like this it's like that's true it's
a it's like it's like the world start
thing it's saving the waters well it's
always like I just wait for you as soon
as like something pops off like LeBron
does this or you know this player does
this I tune in it's you on worldstar
like you know is did you see that you
said you tuning book on me a worldstar
because of what I wanted to bring up to
the to the viewers as a friend yeah uh
is that I noticed and I took down my
video because I said I'm gonna post
video and then my friend pointed out to
me he said you know that a fighter and
the kid they don't follow you and I said
what do you mean I go Bryan Callen did
Brett and job of course well the fighter
in the kid the podcast says which you
probably run no okay do you what's your
name
Kat Kat okay your cat yes okay bro cat
runs it my friends Brendon shop and
Bryan Callen do not follow me and I was
like cuz I'll see you on worldstar I was
like wow that hurt Joyce on PR
skillfully
now who's me I was like nah not one of
them both of them so it had to be a
collective thing between the [ __ ]
think tank and we're talking about when
we say things a great quote cuz the
think tank between do because that
[ __ ] concrete [ __ ] hitter help me
fall Jeff 1.7 million like let's say 1.7
659 and it was 61 but I lost two and I
would like to know when the conversation
happened and I want to be straight here
let's be transfer when did you and cally
collectively go we're not following our
friend Rappaport I wonder I know there's
a [ __ ] conversation don't mean bribes
I've never had it comes it's very
strange and you guys are are you guys
like Lou to be nice to who you do follow
just follow him right now ken has
accessed my Instagram that's
unbelievable do you follow me [ __ ] I
thought I followed you cuz you're on
world yeah all the time hopping and the
Nick do anything I just gotta [ __ ]
take my man slowly to me the Wendy
Williams of London comedy and it could
happen but my man but my man the fact
that it wasn't just you can play count
count 6960 no unless you have big
titties I'm a dude with a great deal for
so there was a collective thing that you
strange Brenda's and he followed you
before like Brendan's like this is what
Brendan follow some of the people like
the generics the Jeff Ross is everybody
loves a world with or off friend of mine
but all these people like all they're
all the check mark all like all these
comedians and like Fresno Travis Barker
a really good friend we know all this
stuff and now like I guarantee you and I
have friends I guarantee there's the top
15 people that you follow hear me and
you are we could say I agree you you
agree if chicken ain't [ __ ] to fit I
call rapper
I know rappers not a bitch-ass
[ __ ] yeah you don't follow me
well I follow you now hunka you follow
him now but the fighter and the cuticle
has always followed you yeah because
because you follow it because you do
that's a business account but personally
said you see how my film career that
invites fair sorry I apologize
I thought I was following you so I'm
gonna fight right now I'm gonna i'ma
[ __ ] your blazer up I'm gonna [ __ ] your
blazed up for you go to Portland dude
don't worry my Blazers like don't don't
worry Franklin that's a new don't tase
me bro this is Cal hey scumbag give me
the toilet hey scumbag hey scumbag come
here check this out scumbag I just I
just asked your friend I asked him this
nice makeup by the way I said to him I
noticed cuz I was gonna do a post oh
yeah I'm doing fighter in the kid and I
posted something and somebody was like
you know those guys don't follow you on
Instagram so and both of you both of you
I want to know collectively be honest
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] mutant you
[ __ ] makeup face mutant be be honest
when did you rendered you in [ __ ]
concrete head sake Brian you're not
gonna follow Rappaport anymore he's our
friend but it looks like earthworm jim
right now in face but wait and don't say
you're 60 and now cuz you know how to
work instagram last night you told me
you were 53 when you were creeping
around the Laugh Factory and you didn't
have a spot that's weird bro that's
weird what were you doing there no let's
stay focused I want to know a hospital
gown I want to know when did you decide
I'm not following my friend Rappaport
and why you're so precious but you
follow other people that if it was
ride-or-die you know you would call my
crap before because my crap is a solid
dude and all these [ __ ] leeches
backstab and he cleans I jerked the ID
hose wheel follow IG O's before I follow
either one of you I follow a gentleman
but you you [ __ ] your and we were
already talking about I want to see the
joke or twice I haven't seen you in it
but
other thing we're talking about today
Callen is this is and you probably have
covered this who whose [ __ ] did you suck
first when you were with Pacino and
Schwarzenegger and I think all rap I had
to hear about it for a week dude he
wouldn't shut up about it
he's senile he's 83 years old he's dumb
[Laughter]
okay well listen I just want to remind
you Brian that had last time I the last
time I guest-hosted it was the highest
downloaded fighter in the kid ever
yeah what's true job we're word word
yeah we're taking over your Instagram
account you makeup face mutant [ __ ] you
let me tell you something that one tweet
is about as with the one second that you
were in the [ __ ] Joker you feel don't
worry you don't have to ask me the fact
that you're asking about social media is
more disrespectful than the fact that
you don't even follow no but I should
have walked out of this hall now bro we
should have walked out of this brother
follow you now I should have came here
punched you in our face what's good
what's good took your account and then
made you follow then bouncing and smack
[ __ ] I do you one more time good I don't
do that before I leave
try anyway listen I got a goat this is
40 43 minutes of fire I know your ladies
your flights at what time 7:00 - and
it's 105 no you're saying I sight this
hot you've shown your age you like to
get there early I know you're saying
yourself god I wish rap would come
around
more often course uh that [ __ ] debt
that that that albatross around my neck
[ __ ] bruh bet Brian Cowen but it's
short and sweet I said I said the cat
it's gonna be short and sweet night when
I say I said 45 minutes of fury Erie and
what did you say cat thumbs up something
like that thumbs up yeah like okay like
sounds good but but do you do you handle
Callens account - no i don't okay so I'm
gonna do a couple things I'm gonna tag
Brennan I expect some repose and I can
hollows your date okay because because I
was I have to say I was like damn that
kind of I was like wait up I'll say that
is weird why would you take the he'll
fall me like oh [ __ ] I was going to
bring it here cuz and even and you know
because you don't have to cancel about
six weeks ago I had to reschedule yeah
I've been hanging on to it for that long
and I stored into it and I was like I'm
not gonna I'm gonna say it on the air
we're talking at the store and text him
but I was like imma say it on the air so
imma blow up his [ __ ] spot we can't
blow or you could been real easy just
hey bro you don't follow my girl [ __ ] my
bat not in my bag not my bed I wanted to
see your eyes flutter and be like oh I
got confused on now I've got an illusion
though I thought you were
WorldStarHipHop I thought you just were
world stuff yeah Brian's holder he can't
hold it against him he doesn't unless
you're a CrossFit dude or gal he is no
he loves CrossFit dude I'll just watch
them staring at CrossFit dude yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]